hi everyone welcome to your daily
equation and today I'm going to focus on
one of the key equations that leads us
to quantum physics quantum mechanics and
this is an equation that Albert Einstein
came up with and he came up with it in
trying to unravel a puzzle that had been
around for I don't know probably a
couple of decades so we need to cast her
minds back again to the year 1905 the
same year that Einstein came up with the
special theory of relativity but now he
is thinking about a different puzzle and
the puzzle has to do with the
photoelectric effect what is that well I
think it was in the late 1800s somebody
will correct my history of science if I
have this wrong and I think it was
Heinrich Hertz who realized that if you
shine a light on a metallic surface in
the right way then the light can
actually cause electrons to be emitted
from that surface so I guess I can
probably probably do even a little
show-and-tell I have a lot of junk
around here you wouldn't think so based
on what you see behind me it looks nice
and neat but I throw everything on this
side of the camera so you can't see it
but I think I do yes I do so I have a
flashlight here I just need something
metallic that I can use the radar
detector
no I I guess I can use this the back I
don't know the back of a measuring
device here a tape measure so imagine
this is my metallic surface and I'm
shining you know this flashlight on the
surface and the idea is that if I do
this in the right way in the right
experimental setup then the light from
the source can cause electrons from the
surface to be ejected outward so this in
itself is not a particular puzzle
because after all light is an
electromagnetic wave an idea that we
will also discuss subsequent to the
discussion today
one of our other discussions of
Maxwell's equations but light carries
energy and so energy slams into the
metallic surface the electrons are
loosely bound to that surface and the
energy from the wave can knock the
electrons free not particularly puzzling
at all but what is puzzling is when you
look at the details of the data because
you would think or at least most people
would think that the kinetic energy the
energy that the electrons have their
speed when they leave the surface should
be determined by the intensity of the
light right after all light is this wave
and the intensity of a wave the
intensity of an ocean wave is given by
its amplitude the ups and downs of the
wave similarly the ups and downs of the
electric and magnetic fields that
comprise the electromagnetic wave that
is light the ups and downs the amplitude
that should determine the energy of the
light naturally terman the energy of the
electrons that are ejected but when you
look at the data that's not at all the
case you know it determines the kinetic
energy of the electrons that are not
free from the surface the color of the
light it's frequency that is how quickly
it oscillates up and down determines the
at least the maximum kinetic energy of
the ejected electrons the intensity of
the light does determine something else
it determines the number of electrons
that are ejected from the surface but
their energy comes from the color of the
light so this was a puzzle that Albert
Einstein starts to think about and he
ultimately comes up with a solution and
that solution I can actually show you
the paper right here so this is his 1905
paper on the photoelectric effect
1905 is often described as Einstein's
miracle year he writes a handful of
papers any two or three of which could
have themselves received Nobel Prize but
it's actually this paper not his paper
on special relativity not his paper and
equals mc-squared it's this paper for
which he received the 1921 Nobel Prize
in Physics and it is in this paper that
he unravels this paradox of the
photoelectric effect and let me just
describe to you what he finds so the
picture let me just bring up my iPad
here good so the picture that we have at
least that we're trying to figure out
here imagine that this is my metallic
surface and let me just describe light
as a wave coming in so this is the usual
picture you've got this electromagnetic
wave slamming into the surface and
you've got say let's say little
electrons in here and these electrons
are flying out and surprisingly their
energy deters determined by the color of
the light how does Einstein explain this
well Einstein makes use of a different
image of light a different picture a
different description of what a beam of
light actually is he actually goes back
to an idea that we can trace to Isaac
Newton himself or Newton thought that
light was actually made of a torrent of
particles we call those particles of
light now photons let me use that
language a torrent of photons as opposed
to some kind of wave-like phenomenon but
that idea was dropped when people like
Thomas and Maxwell showed apparently
that light is an electromagnetic way but
Einstein kind of goes back to an old
idea of light as a stream of particles
in fact I can show you in this sort of
fancier version of
demonstration now done in animation you
see that from the flashlight that beam
of light Einstein says is actually a
stream of particles now how does this
resolve the problem well let me go back
to this picture over here let me erase
this idea of light as a wave and in its
place let me describe it as a collection
of particles each of which is flying
down to the surface let me focus on one
of them this guy over here and imagine
what's going on when a photon hits the
surface and ejects an electron is a
collision between the photon and the
electron and that's one-to-one collision
is what ejects the electron and clearly
then the energy of the ejected electron
the energy of the electron will be
determined by the energy of the photon
that hits it now
Einstein says in order to match the data
that the energy of that photon must be
proportional to the color of the light
which is the frequency of its
oscillations and indeed you can go
further and make that proportionality
into an equality which is today's daily
equation by using a number called H
which is known as Planck's constant
after Max Planck and the equation
therefore that he comes to is e equals H
nu and this idea of light as a
collection of particles explains why it
would be that the kinetic energy of the
ejected electron would depend on the
color of the light because the energy of
each individual photon via this equation
is depended
upon the frequency of the light
dependent therefore on the color of the
light and we can go even further why
would it be that the number of these
electrons that are ejected is dependent
upon the intensity of the light well now
that's quite obvious the intensity of
the light is nothing but the number of
photons higher intensity greater number
of photons greater number of photons
greater number of collisions with
electrons greater number of collisions
greater number of electrons that will be
emitted so that's why the number of
ejected electrons is determined by the
intensity of the light because the
intensity is just the number of photons
and the kinetic energy of each of those
electrons at least the maximum kinetic
energy that any of them can have is
determined by the color of the light
because the energy of each photon is
proportional to the frequency of the
light so it's kind of a beautiful
blending of wave-like ideas I mean
frequency afterall is a notion that has
to do with a wave and Einstein says take
that wave-like idea and blend it into a
particle description of light so it's
not quite going back to the Newtonian
picture of particles of light it's not
quite using the pure wave-like
description of light that came to us
from James Clark Maxwell and previous
analyses and experiment Einstein kind of
blends them together using a wave-like
concept the frequency of the light but
using it to define equality of the
particulate ingredients making up light
namely the energy of each individual
photon and this really is a profound
move toward the quantum mechanical
description of energy and matter these
are ideas that will take up further as
we continue on in our description of the
fundamental equations of quantum
mechanics
but for today that's all I wanted to
cover this fantastically profound
equation e equals H nu introduced to
explain the photoelectric effect which
launches the quantum revolution so
that's today's equation in your daily
equation looking forward to carrying on
this discussion next time but for today
that's all
take care